all right carl um carl where'd you grow
up where are you from originally i grew
up in kansas city kansas county um for
first seven years of my life and then we
moved i got adopted and moved to
oklahoma for a year and then we moved
down to galveston texas oh wow so tell
me about your family you had mom and dad
initially um yeah my my biological
parents uh
my mom was a prostitute and my dad was a
biker and he got in trouble um
he killed a
prostitute
in front of me when i was a child
you saw it yeah i was like my earliest
childhood man
where'd your life go from there
um well
i became pretty violent you know and
i got adopted my mom couldn't take care
of me and two kids on her own
being strung out and
you know
like she was and so we got adopted
to this catholic family and
they were real strict
and i knew i was old enough to know that
they weren't my family so
uh i became very uh oppositional you
know
and they uh
they couldn't handle me anymore because
i tried to catch school on fire
i stabbed a kid at school
and i was just too much for him so and i
was running away all the time
so they gave me back to the state so
from 11 to 18 i was in group homes and
that's where i learned to do drugs you
know pretty much was in the group homes
i raised myself this is where uh in
texas in texas yeah in texas
you graduate high school huh did you
graduate high school um no i got my ged
when i was in prison right
and um
[Music]
after that where'd you go
um
well i had this this one group home i
was in and uh like south of fort worth
i became real good friends with the
count with a couple of the counselors
there and
um
this lady janine um
she was like she was working there she
was safe enough to get a sex change she
was
she was
she was a different person you know
uh
then the seventh-day adventist community
that this place was in you know where
she lived
so
uh
i took to her because you know i was
i liked her she was really cool
and she always told me whenever i turned
18 if i needed somewhere to go that
she'd count on me i could count on her
for a place to live
so i got a hold of them when i turned 18
and
i went and lived with them for a while
and that's when i really started using
drugs a lot you know because they did a
lot of drugs what kind of drugs are you
playing around with them um
i started out uh i started out for the
longest time just smoking weed
and then
i got turned on to some speed
one time with these two lesbian friends
that i had
and they gave me a line of it and i
really liked it so
uh this other girl that i knew named kay
she wanted me to uh
hang out with her but she shot up and i
wanted to impress her because i was
trying to get with her so
i started shooting up you know and
that's how i got started and it was
downhill from there i got to institute
some cocaine and i started shooting coke
and it was all bad i got my first prison
case
and
went to eight years
got out and started back on the dope and
from that point it was like everything i
did i had to shoot up you know because
it was the only way i got high on
anything
how old are you now i'm 44 44. and
you've been
on drugs most of the time i've been on
drugs since i was 14. wow
yeah
and what is your
favorite drug today uh
and crystal meth
and math too
yeah
i can't have one without the other is
that right yeah yeah i've met quite a
few people that do both yeah what do you
do both
um i do the crystal because it keeps me
from overdosing
you know
it helps keep from uh
when the fentanyl is too strong as long
as i got crystal in it it keeps me alive
i think i mean have you a deed uh i
haven't od yet no
i've been lucky i've had like all my
friends have died from this stuff you
know and it's sad
it's really sad you know
do you have kids
i have one son
where is he he's in kansas city
i miss him you know i haven't got seen
him since he was five he just turned 14
and
you know i just i
i know that i can't be in his life as
long as i'm strung out like i am
yeah i have a place to live in kansas
city i just i have a house
i just
i don't know i don't want to be there
strung out like this right yeah
and you've been on skid row for how long
i've been on skid row for 11 years yeah
yeah you're in a tent yep yeah living in
a tent
how do you support your drug habit
i'm a booster i boost i still gain some
stores
and i sell them
you ever get caught um yeah i've been
cut a couple times um not as many not as
many times as other people i'm pretty
good at it
what's your technique um
i don't know i guess it's just my look
you know yeah there's a lot to do i look
like a blue shirt so i've talked to some
people who uh
just fill their backpack and rush out
the back door
yeah the other ones are yeah they just
hit the security the emergency exits
yeah yeah who do you sell it to uh just
people on the street a fence offense
that's right yeah they're confident
uh there's people that resell it you
know i don't want to get too much into
it but yeah i don't want the details
there's a big
a lot bigger black market than people
think yeah i'll just put it that way
it's a it's a pretty big deal
you know it's amazing how big it is
really and how people get away with it
you know
so what's what's your biggest regret
looking back at your life
my biggest regret is walking out on my
family yeah
my kid's mom and my kid yeah
how old was your son
he's 14 now 14. yep
did you have dreams of doing something
else with your life when you were young
yeah i wanted to
yeah uh
at first i wanted to be i wanted to work
in a zoo
i always thought that would be cool and
then
i
got a hold of my first indiana jones
movie and i wanted to be an
archaeologist
yeah that was
and then uh when i was in the group
homes i
i took to like trying to figure out like
like different professions so i would
like talk to the nurses and stuff a lot
and
i thought about becoming something in
the medical field or something working
with other kids that are disadvantaged
you know
but
that failed this would all be great
those would have all been great yeah
yeah
uh regardless you know like i'm you know
a lot of people come to me for help
because uh
you know
i i helped a lot of people i just i
don't and i do it without you know
without fail without argument or you
know uh it's just something that drives
me you know what it's like as long as
i'm helping somebody i'm doing some some
kind of good in the world in what ways
do you help um
when people are dope sick or you know
they know they can come to me and i'll
you know i'll get them well if i can get
them well
um
if they need help with a couple bucks or
whatever you know just ain't gonna help
you know if someone needs someone to
crash for the night you know they can
always come to my spot and
you know they don't have to worry about
getting
anybody messing with them or stealing
their stuff you know right and that's
something that's really big people
always get their stuff stolen out here
do you have any friends
um
i have a couple people i call friends
not two minutes i'm alone
you know
i don't know
i like helping people but at the same
time i don't have time for idiots
and it seems to me like there's a lot of
idiots out there
what are you afraid of
spiders
no i'm afraid i'm gonna i'm afraid of
death i really am i'm afraid this shit's
gonna kill me yeah playing around with
fentanyl is no joke yeah
and the worst part of it is i shoot it i
don't smoke it you know i i do
intravenous drugs
and that makes it a lot worse you know
i've been lucky so far yeah so many
people dying in the last few months from
family yeah i've had a lot of friends
die
a lot
well over 20 yeah 11 30
probably 20 30. somewhere 30 something
i think i'm at
you know i have to resuscitate somebody
at least twice a week
you carry your narcan with you
yeah yeah i keep narcan yeah
do you feel like your
the path your life took was somehow
[Music]
in your dna from your mom and dad yeah
prostitute the biker for appearances
probably
yeah it's pretty rough
all my family's been to prison except
for my grandma
um
we got downtown
all my uncles are lifers
my dad did 38 years he just got out a
year ago
it's been really rough really rough
i want to quit you know i want to stop
doing drugs
but
it seems like whenever i do try
i just get so bored there's nothing to
do you know i feel like i have nothing
to do because i'm just
so
i get really messed up emotionally you
know i'm real sensitive and
it's uh what kind of emotions do you go
through a lot of guilt
guilt over your son because i've done
yeah i've done a lot of shitty [ __ ] and
i've done a lot of things that
i regret you know
and
um
i just wish that my blackberry took a
different path you know
i look back you know i'm 44 i'm i'm
getting too old to do anything really
now and
i don't want this the rest of my life i
really don't
you know
what do you wish what do you wish had
been different about your childhood or
about your life
i wish i grew up in beverly hills
different parents perhaps yeah but you
know i accept my
i accept
my story for what it is you know and
i mean
it's not done being wrote do you feel
like life is unfair
yeah you're you're a delta
i no i i don't i don't call it unfair
you know because
you're born to who you're born to you
know and
you're giving you know i was given
opportunities that i could have took but
i chose not to because i wanted to party
instead
you know i thought that was more
important
you know and
it wound up taking its toll on you know
and it sucks
but i accept it for what it is and i and
i know that it's going to be a great
story to tell to help people one day
yeah
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
uh
that
you know um
i feel that the most important thing to
me is that uh
that um
i've learned a fate
is uh
is real
you know and that
you know i had a
i was in love with this girl for five
years and
when i went to prison this last time
she thought i was dead
and uh she killed herself you know and
lived with that every day
you know
why because you disappeared
yeah what did you think about that
because i shot this guy and killed him
and uh
i was hiding out from that
and uh she didn't know where i was at
and i just disappeared and so everybody
thought this guy's people retaliated and
kidnapped and killed me
because nobody knew where i was at
and uh
nobody had heard from me or any of that
mess
and when i got out
it was like people were tripping you
know i had a friend over at the needle
exchange he
fainted because he started seeing a
ghost you know he didn't
know that i was alive you know he was
like one of my best friends
before i went you know i went to prison
and
uh
oh man
it's it's something you know she did it
in a very brutal manner too and she was
a very vague girl but
i loved it with all my heart you know
and i did it everything for her and
when i didn't find out that she killed
herself so i got out the day i got out
and i don't mean to be nosy but i'll be
nosy how did she do it yeah she uh
doused herself with gasoline in a gas
station and caught herself on fire
yeah
and that's pretty gruesome yeah
it kills me you know because
she lives in my life you know she was
everything and
she was the one that was actually
helping me get my [ __ ] together you know
and i was helping her and
i was the best man she had ever been
with you know even though of the
situation we were in
but uh
our family really liked me because you
know i uh
i made her happy you know
something that she's never really been
in her life
that's heavy
that's a lot to carry around every day
yeah it is and you know the only way i
can mask it really is
with drugs you know i feel
you know because i don't get to talk to
enough people i can't show my emotions
out here because
you know people take advantage of that
and
so it's really hard you know
it's really hard
wow
all right carl thank you so much for
sharing your your story
and i wish you the best of luck out
there thanks thank you
you